this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app and it's
great the cash app has done something
amazing they've introduced the cash card
a new black debit card that you can
design yourself via the app it allows
you to use the cash that you keep in the
app anywhere you want now you have the
cash app which is the best way to pay
people back plus the all new cash card
talk about this more later on in the
show
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now I never know what episode it
is but that's because I'm flying by the
seat of my pants flying by the seat of
you know now I'm sitting here the video
episode is back the video podcast is
back so just if you want if you're
listening to it on the podcast and if
you prefer watching it on youtube go on
the YouTube channel not you boob even
though that's what I said
YouTube and you can go on youtube and
watch the [ __ ] watch watch our cult
leader may be on be on camera and I got
my [ __ ] true baby shirt on which is
ILI's [ __ ] you can probably see it on
the video it's got a little bit if you
it's kind of like you know it's got the
elder pin on it embroidered not
embroidered it's just screen printed but
I don't know what the [ __ ] it is but
it's cuz of the stock have you ever seen
that [ __ ] your business card is [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is it your business card
is a piece of [ __ ] crap dude the guy who
does the business card your business
card is crap ma okay so this guy who's
got hair that looks like Jason Priestley
in non Attilan oh he's doing a video and
he's talking about how his business card
is way better than all the other
business cards and it's a
a book it's a goddamn pop-up book he's
like this card is [ __ ] it's flimsy
but and they pulls out his card he said
it's foil embossed and it's you
literally open it up and it's like a
pop-up book imagine if somebody had
first of all imagine if someone hands
you a business card at all that person
can't trust them period if anybody hand
you a business card and he's not a
driver you are untrustworthy he hit I
mean maybe if you're a lawyer but if
you're a lawyer you're already
untrustworthy but if I mean imagine just
being a guy with like a company and
handy hey man we got a talk here's my
business card
and if then the e they hand it to you
there's one way to hand you the business
a business card by the way and it's
holding it with the index finger and the
middle finger and that means you think
you're the [ __ ] and that means Y
untrustworthy dude I mean first of all
this guy who [ __ ] is holding his
business card it's the cover of a
goddamn CD case hey man if it doesn't
fit in the wallet scone in the trash
what's the Mitch Hedberg joke is like
when somebody hands you a flier and
there's like here you throw this away
this is so truth the way this guy leans
forward showing you his business card is
unbelievable
no business card should open up die-cut
its foil embossed what is the [ __ ]
upper deck special edition [ __ ] [ __ ]
man
but yeah anyway I'm back I'm back from
[ __ ] Australia now this is the for
I'm it I did my Australian tour let me
thank you guys first of all oh you guys
the Australian babies came came out man
you guys [ __ ] came out in droves you
came to the show he's really cool uh I
have a few Australian friends
in my in my you know life but they're
all here okay
I like them I liked it you know if you
know me you listen to the podcast you
know me a little bit you know I like
weirdo friends I got an Italian friend
always looks like he's looking a
fireworks I got a [ __ ] you know weird
quiet friends I have an Irish friend
that looks just like me
do you not I'm talking about just I like
weirdos okay I have a guy that sounds
like Beavis that's my friend but this I
have Australian friends when you go to
Australia now I've been I haven't been
the foreigner in a long time I haven't
been the foreigner since I was 19 in
Italy and in its same same 19 in in
London I mean in Canada doesn't count
you know but I was the foreigner for two
weeks dude and when you have to as a
foreigner listen to everybody with that
Australian accent first of all I was
just like hankerin to meet an American
you know long everybody was talking like
this and I didn't know what the [ __ ]
anybody was saying for a while and one
time I was in the I started I was
telling this story on stage but I was
like I think I feel like our struggles
[ __ ] with you a little bit because oh
wait because uh because I would be I was
like hey where's the L I asked some guy
where's the elevator and he's like was
that now and I was like where's the
elevator he's like excuse me I said the
L what's the elevator and he said could
you say that again and I was like I
already said three times don't know how
to [ __ ] say it without making this guy
sound like a [ __ ] [ __ ] now so I was
just like the elevator where is it
and he said and then I said oh the lift
he said I was right down there like made
me say it you know no gonna let this
shitty American trying to [ __ ] say Y
elevator when you know we don't say yell
Aveda
but so so uh so yeah so I
but everybody with that accent everyone
has that accent and I know you know that
but it's like really weird to see it on
guys and girls and [ __ ] and they're just
all like guys are you going hey hey you
going
hi are you going it's where you're going
or how are you are you going how are you
going walking how by car hey you going
by plane but they do it I thought it was
something that they just summed said but
they all say that
so on the way to Australia though the
guy had the [ __ ] most cartoony
Australian accent it was like Australian
mixed with like Nazi German like he was
just like when we get out to Australia
yeah yeah that's actually exactly how it
started
he was like have you tried high blows up
and if you need anything I'll come over
in boys and yeah um but he was like
welcome to Australia and it was like it
was like no matter what he was saying on
the [ __ ] thing the phone-- thing for
the whole flight he was also like
casually like pleasuring himself on his
balls it was like we have got a lot of
different options for meals if you like
just take a look in your menu and I'll
just be up here near the cockpit rubbing
my balls
um but yeah so anyway but Australia was
good man I it's so funny dude like
people were like I was cancelling [ __ ]
left and right like because I had a club
or the club the promoter was like hey
man we set you up some stuff I was gonna
go to like the animal reserve don't wan
and then I was gonna do a bridge climb
in Sydney don't one and I'd wake up and
be like hey man now I'm not gonna go to
that thing and the thing is I let you
know here's something man I want to talk
about we got to stop letting people
[ __ ] talk into stuff now it's fine to
be open-minded I get it and this is
gonna sound a little narrow-minded but I
didn't want to do the bridge client and
I know I don't do stuff and my buddy
Joel was texting me is like dude if you
don't do stuff in Australia I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you you're in another
country you got to do this [ __ ] and I
was like you know he's right you got to
open up yourself to new ideas maybe I'll
get new material and so I was like okay
maybe I'll do the bridge class and the
night the day before the bridge climb I
was like I don't think I want to do the
bridge climb and I was in the apparently
there's like this bridge and Sydney you
climb and it's beautiful when you get on
the top of it and of course it is but
guess what you don't really have to do
that stuff anymore cuz Google and also I
that scene always comes to mind the the
[ __ ] scene in what is the the Good
Will Hunting where Matt Damon is like
talking to Robin Williams on a bench of
course cuz it's s his cinematic but hey
who talks to anybody on a [ __ ] park
bench when does that ever happen have
you ever had a conversation with anybody
on a goddamn park bench no how come in
every movie there's a scene where
somebody's talking to somebody else on a
goddamn park bench hey I've got an even
better question where's a park where's a
park dude if somebody said to me meet me
at a park I'd go like this uh where is
it that where's that Park what are we in
a [ __ ] romantic comedy what are we in
that [ __ ] David Duchovny mini driver
one that came out for some reason
returned to me it couldn't be more of a
[ __ ] romantic comedy return to me
return to me sick [ __ ]
return to me what was I talking about oh
the yeah so oh yeah when they're like
when they're like you know you know what
it's like you know how they made the
Sistine Chapel you know all about the
thing but have you ever been there and
looked at it and felt what it feels like
to be there and when I was a kid I was
like damn did Robert Robin Williams has
a good point but also Google wasn't that
big then and now you can pretty much go
anywhere and do a 360 you know you can
pretty much go anywhere and do a 360
I can go to [ __ ] Zimbabwe if I want
to right now mmm a living room and do a
360 and see all sorts of [ __ ]
whatever it's like in Zimbabwe Zimbabwe
that's a crazy name ah so high did you
ever think about how Zimbabwe this is a
[ __ ] word so anyway so so so so I
didn't so I was like I don't think I'm
gonna go to the bridge climb and then
there one of the other promoters on the
tour because I was on my show and she
was like oh you gotta you gotta it's
beautiful you got a guy and I was like
yeah right okay
and I'll let her make me think all right
I'll go and then I woke up in the
morning I didn't want to [ __ ] go I
should be true to myself dude true baby
I should be true to my god to himself I
didn't want to go she's like no you
should go and you get [ __ ] talked
into it and then I wake up in the
morning I don't want to go and I texted
I you know what I'm not gonna go and I
felt guilty about that
I felt like I was letting them down [ __ ]
that first of all I didn't [ __ ] set
up the tour the the bridge climb I'm
gonna do it I don't want to
my producers 3:16 Zimbabwe and it's like
y-you know it just looks like Philly
just looks like [ __ ] Philly so so
yeah so i i i i i didn't do the bridge
club and I didn't do the [ __ ] animal
reserve and I didn't see a [ __ ]
kangaroo and I don't give a [ __ ] how
about that dude I didn't see a kangaroo
you know why cuz I've seen that [ __ ]
a kangaroo flexing on Instagram I've
seen that [ __ ] you seen that [ __ ]
kangaroo with shoulders for [ __ ] sake
kangaroos have shoulders naw I don't
care I want to see a koala [ __ ] my
medicine man I got dogs at home they're
the same [ __ ] thing you know so so I
didn't do it and I [ __ ] you know what
I did I walked around the cities took it
in my mom was like you gotta sightsee
make yourself to it so I went to that
[ __ ] Bondi Beach everyone my buddies
who are musicians were hitting me up and
they were like dude hottest chicks ever
best-looking people in the world went to
Bondi Beach guess what thug Lee's were
out there was zero good-looking people
zero now I understand it was an overcast
day but what's that mean the troglodytes
come out Bondi Beach you know I went
there the uglies were out walked around
and then [ __ ] hopped in an uber back
and I touched the water because I felt
like I should touch the water because I
wanted it was so far away and then I
went back to them and I just I wanted to
drink by the way the coffee in Australia
is so much [ __ ] better it's
unbelievable I know I think I said this
in my last one but it's like dude I
don't understand what the [ __ ] is
America doing pissing in it hey America
you wiping you [ __ ] with the ice
cubes they've got better ice cubes
they've got better [ __ ] water they've
got better coffee beans the only thing
they don't have better is the [ __ ]
cops hey first of all I'm no scientist
and I don't know the reason but why the
[ __ ] if you put cold liquid in a hot
coffee cup it turns to a [ __ ]
marshmallow why does the cup get soggy
it's still liquid just because it's cold
it [ __ ] soggies it up that's very
weird
but they don't have those [ __ ]
plastic cups and if they do they haunt
they have the dome lids put the [ __ ]
flat lid on it and keep it [ __ ]
see-through baby if I'm drinking
something cold I want it see-through I
want to see it if it's hot put it in a
[ __ ] hot [ __ ] but if it's cold
keep it see-through do these are the
rules man it's [ __ ] 2017 we figured
all the [ __ ] out don't go backwards but
flying in Australia is amazing dude you
let you just walk on there like I as a
cow how you go in you have to take your
shoes off now or do that cool do I need
to put do I need to walk through this I
just don't have any bones on your hair
okay get on the plane oh cool sit down
would you like a stroke job do the first
thing I get when I get to the Australia
the first thing I get is a text from the
promoter I am here in Sydney at the
airport just the outside the lounge
having a filthy ciggy I I thought he was
joking
even a filthy siggy and then he did it
and I was joking but he did it again he
was like waiting for you outside the
hotel giving a feel thing siggy filthy
siggy dude
first of all we know it's bad for you oh
dude the [ __ ] the the the you know
and you know in America that all that
[ __ ] could tobacco corporations they
they try to make you like they try to
sell it's so obvious that they try to
sell [ __ ] smokes to 12-year olds you
know with the bright colors on the boxes
and [ __ ] in [ __ ] Australia they
literally have mouth cancer and dead
babies on the [ __ ] boxes and he was
still like it'll be like hey it like
just so you know you can get these but
you're gonna get oh I can say it's so
gross dude and people still smoke this
[ __ ] look at the foot one look at the
foot one dude and these people are just
carrying these boxes around and I got a
look at them hey I'll take secondhand
smoke before I'll take [ __ ] looking
at some some [ __ ] cancer canker Tong
uh a filthy siggy dude I'm so sick of
seeing everybody on [ __ ] Halloween
with all your stupid how about people
who are tweeting pictures hey my cousin
dressed up as a [ __ ] thing
Halloween's canceled Halloween's over
hey he won Halloween no he lost it he
lost it he's a loser let's get one thing
straight
if you dressed up for Halloween and
you're 30 no matter what you what no
matter what costume you put on you know
what you went as Okuda that's what you
went as you dressed up as Napoleon
Dynamite you have kids no you didn't you
dressed up as a CUDA what you dressed up
you dressed up as Wednesday Addams with
your tits out
I don't remember Wednesday as an atom's
showing her [ __ ] fake knockers it
kuda that's what you dressed up as so
tomorrow's Halloween and if you're
listening to this on Tuesday today's
Halloween I want you as babies to put on
your [ __ ] you CUDA shirts on if
you're not dressing up and go as [ __ ]
khuda exposures okay you're not a
[ __ ] you didn't dress up you dress up
your [ __ ] 45 you're the fun guy at
the party you know what I don't want to
be ever the fun guy at the party you
know why cuz you boring are those up yet
by the way we got new [ __ ] merch and
this shit's the most banger [ __ ] we got
new merch we got these true baby tees
first of all but we got the [ __ ]
illest no kuda shirts you got to go on
the website krisily accom or what is it
Kristin whatever is Chris Leo calm and
go to the store and it's got the [ __ ]
no kuda sign it's the [ __ ] dude
but dude if you dressed up for Halloween
you dressed up as a CUDA that's what you
did man
unless you're 12 hey you 12 go have fun
eat some candy
you [ __ ] 40 he barn you don't if
you're the guy who has the best
Halloween costume at the party you're
doing all this other [ __ ] instead of
and a personality it's what you're doing
develop skills you did oh my god dude
my producer just wrote me he dressed up
as a shark one year and didn't go
anywhere two nights ago
first of all wasn't mean Halloween why'd
you do it on set were you gonna go
somewhere people came to your house
people came in so he dressed up as a
shark crazy and insane
I guess Halloween just got big in
Australia like over the past 25 years
that's what the person who was smoking a
filthy cig he was trying to tell me what
my [ __ ] producer one higher he
dressed up as a shark two nights ago
not even on Halloween and invited people
over did they wear out costumes one
person how do you became over a shark in
two and in two days before Halloween
three days before Halloween and one
other person dressed up as what like
Sherlock Holmes a chameleon it was like
the saddest zoo ever with too many
keepers ten zookeepers a chameleon and a
shark out of water dude I saw some
[ __ ] eye somebody dressed up as a
coot they said I look I'm dressed up as
I had to keep it real he had on his kuta
shirt and he was standing next to a guy
[ __ ] these first of all if you're gonna
dress up as a ha as a thing dress up as
Wednesday Addams dress up as a vampire
dress up as a werewolf dress up as a
cowboy dress up as a [ __ ] demon you
know what you don't dress up as I saw
one girl she was in a slip and she had
the word Freud on it and she was a
Freudian slip dude why is your nose
facing my nose have it faced the same
way step out Google dude
not cute you're not clever this guy
dressed up he had a t-shirt on that says
life and he was holding lemons see ya
dude if you have to have a costume and
you have to have the word of the costume
on your t-shirt you didn't try hard
enough or you didn't try little enough
you're in no-man's land
take it off put on a button-down chill
or [ __ ] put on some fangs and go as a
[ __ ] vampire these costumes dude you
didn't try or you tried too hard stop it
put on jeans and a t-shirt chill
last time I dressed up I was [ __ ]
Ethan Hawke and training day with four
other guys who were Ethan Hawke from
training day I was like 24 I think maybe
one year after that I dressed up as
Keanu Reeves from Constantine all I
really did was [ __ ] roll my sleeves
up but man I don't know Halloween dude I
just any time these holidays happen no
Christmas I love Thanksgiving even
though it's bad there historically it's
shitty it doesn't bother me in the way
that the other holidays bother me or
it's like I just can't wait until it's
over
Halloween st. Patrick's Day [ __ ] any
any holiday New Year's any holiday we're
drinking and going [ __ ] out is the
thing I just I can't wait for it to end
go out any I've always been like this
anytime you go anytime you're expected
to do something because society wants
you to do something I [ __ ] like I
could never be in a frat didn't want to
go to college didn't want to [ __ ]
that's why I do stand-up comedy anytime
there's a team to [ __ ] out of here man I
got to have rules now we put in oh
there's it there's a thing now where I
gotta have more rules already there's
already the law all
follow the law but anytime I gotta like
go to school and all you can't chew gum
in the [ __ ] class ah see ya you're
gonna tell me where I can't [ __ ] chew
gum what is this what are we in a
[ __ ] would have been communist Russia
[ __ ] out of here hey you you gotta wear
a tie you gotta wear a tie get the [ __ ]
out of here do it you can tell me what
kind of shoes I got a [ __ ] where you
no no I'm so happy to be back in LA dude
when I got back in LA hey dude this
[ __ ] thing man how do I this [ __ ]
might keep sliding the [ __ ] over dude
it's just so annoying dude it's just
always swinging and [ __ ] sucking and
[ __ ] dude there we go
[ __ ] sucking and [ __ ] man so yeah
so I'm just so happy to be in LA and you
know what dude you know what I got to
tell you man this podcast dude I'm
chilling and you're chilling with me
this is a cult you understand done annoy
say this over and over again but we're
chilling dude and you're listening to me
and I'm happy you're listening to me and
we're just hanging the [ __ ] out do it
there's no agenda here I know I talked
about getting the log cabin in the woods
and all that [ __ ] and your guarantor
doing it one day and we're getting the
elders by the way the elders are
stocking up dude I got some elders on
some on some back log here we I'm proud
of you [ __ ] you understand like
a daddy and a mommy I'm both dude and
and and we're stocking up the we're
stocking up the elders and we're sending
out those pins and and but what we're
doing here is chilling right now we're
chilling and I'm a happy [ __ ]
and you dudes are chilling too and you
chicks are chilling too and we're just
having a good time
and listen to me right
cubical we were driving somewhere how
about when people get mad because
somebody a guy dressed up as a chick for
Halloween and it's like they're like oh
no dude I'm so [ __ ] sick of people
getting offended over costumes I don't
give a [ __ ] how about that and it's the
oh [ __ ] I'm a white guy so I can't say
that well how about this
yeah don't give a [ __ ] put on a wig it
doesn't matter
you got a [ __ ] put on a wig who cares
you want to be the Chiquita banana
[ __ ] girl for Halloween and you got
broad shoulders in a [ __ ] get some
bananas and put on a [ __ ] whatever
that hat is she has I don't know put on
those [ __ ] big-ass earrings and be
the Chiquita banana girl oh it offend a
costume offends you alright alright okay
alright yeah I get it don't [ __ ]
paint your face black don't be a [ __ ]
idiot don't be a [ __ ] but chill you
know look at
look at it let's look at this most uh
how about when you click on a website
and you click on a website and then and
then it's bloating and then all of a
sudden it just [ __ ] goes away and
then the oh my god well I mean Holocaust
victim this is something being sold
anything involving blackface transphobic
costumes hold on what does it say here
go up this [ __ ] granny costume was
pulled from Walmart after facing
backlash from consumers who pointed out
that a Moxon settee arises transgender
women in addition to using transfer
transphobic slur what's the transfer oh
it was called [ __ ] cranny Oh God
I mean see here's the thing just if
you're a [ __ ] big enough idiot
I see here's the thing I want to say
dress up well you want to dress up as
but then there's [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
then it's like everyone's [ __ ] it all
up a refugee Jesus Christ a terrorist
the zombie versions of recently deceased
celebrities oh wow this is stupid
see this [ __ ] isn't offensive it's just
stupid go up go up this one it this Ana
rec SIA costume trivializes eating
disorders not to mention it's a terrible
pun it's just stupid it's just dumb
you're a dumb [ __ ] if you think that
that's clever how about I'm offended
about how [ __ ] stupid that is what is
this you
lion killer dentist Halloween costume
look at this a mentally ill person
wearing a straitjacket as well as
anything I'll [ __ ] shut up shut the
[ __ ] up
go ahead go up go up look at this
wearing a straitjacket as well as any
other equipment typically associated
with the institutionalization of someone
with mental illness trivializes how
devastating these conditions can be dude
don't do Halloween then don't go to a
party if you're gonna be offensive
look at these morons dressed up as 9/11
buildings on fire how about just how
stupid that is it's just so dumb people
dress up as as the buildings on it's
just dumb offensive is like to have it
hurt your feelings is this like just
they're just dumb you know people
feelings are hurt so much now it's just
unbelievable like what george w bush did
grabbing that girl's his ass and making
that [ __ ] idiotic joke hey who's your
favorite magician David Copperfield and
then he of [ __ ] grabbed her but yeah
that's like shame on him what a [ __ ]
idiot for doing that here's the deal
dude did that did that scar you for life
did that did that scar you for life did
that scar you did a 93 year old guy pat
me on the ass saying hey my favorite
magician is David Copperfield did that
scar you I don't know
rape scars you sexual assault scars yeah
but look I'm a guy so I haven't [ __ ]
dealt with this [ __ ] my whole life you
know being I mean a lot of times people
[ __ ] you know people objectify me
sure it happens I'm [ __ ] out there
you know
and I can be seen I'm in the [ __ ]
public eye I had I actually had a girl
woman in her 60s at least asked for a
picture with me and grabbed legitimately
grabbed my my my [ __ ] and balls and
squeeze them like groped me I [ __ ]
forgot about it until now it didn't make
me mad yeah
did I say hey what the [ __ ] are you
doing yeah um I forgot about it until
now uh so it didn't scar me now I don't
live with the I don't live with that I
don't live with you know I don't live as
a you know I'm not I'm not what do you
call it objectified like a woman is I'm
not you know I don't live with that fear
of being raped everywhere I go like like
women do so it's different for me 100%
sure of course
understand George Bush what he did was
it was a [ __ ] it was shameful and it was
stupid and it was mostly not funny and
offenders
David coppaFeel but to call that sexual
assault that's that word needs to be
looked at that word needs to be looked
at assault you know what he was doing
Pervin that's what he was doing he was
Pervin and Pervin is not okay but also
it's not assault
he was Pervin if your night
hey don't perv and the older you get the
easier it is to perv because you start
getting to that creepy territory like
I'm a 37 year old guy if I check a girl
out at Starbucks is it Pervin I'll tell
you what not if she's [ __ ] 32 if
she's 20 is it pervert
it's a little bit more Pervin okay but
if your [ __ ] 93 and you're checking
out a 20 year old girl your Pervin dude
I just would the with the assault word
you know what Harvey Weinstein did was
assault what george w bush did was
straight Pervin dude and I'm not saying
it's okay I would not do that but I also
wouldn't think it's funny to say hey
who's your favorite magician David
Copperfield Oh God that's so not funny
but come on man I want to know if that
scarred her for life because somebody
made a horrible joke and [ __ ] felt
her but I don't know I don't know all
right here we hey hey is hey anyway you
shouldn't do sexual assault texture
whether you're looking for a dependable
political reporting high quality
storytelling or the latest on culture
and entertainment magazines deliver it
all with high-quality writing and
beautiful photography and now you can
get all your magazines in one place
texture the texture app gives you
unlimited access to over 200 premium
magazines texture has leading titles
like time the Atlantic The New Yorker
Vanity Fair and wired and right now you
can try texture for free discuss your so
it's great because I get the app and
I've I like it and you can you can get
on your iPad which is why I use it
III I guess you can get on your phone or
iPad it's cool cuz you look at it all
the the magazine magazines and you can
flip through it and it's because of the
stock
it's a jump from one magazine to another
one and you don't have to take a new app
you know you don't have to get the
magazine app you just have all the
magazines in there you don't also have
to fill up your book bag with a bunch of
magazines it's cool
you got your the back issues and you got
them anytime anywhere just write in your
iPad to start your free texture free
trial go to texture calm Congrats
/ Congrats textured calm / Congrats if
you choose to continue podcast listeners
will get texture for just $9.99 a month
that's over 30% off they're listed price
there are also great gift options
available for the holiday season go to
texture comm / congrats to start your
free trial today
that's texture calm / Congrats texture
calm / Congrats
set it to much so look okay
saucy now I hate shopping for alcohol
especially since I don't drink I don't
know what I'm getting I wish I could
have beer wine or liquor delivered for a
long time so I don't have to deal with
it I always make my friend go do it
well someone finally decided to do
something about it
here at saucy introducing saucy the
alcohol delivery app saucy delivers your
favorite wine beer and liquor right to
your front door or on demand
it's like lyft for alcohol deliver beer
wine and liquor to your door in in two
days or less nationwide no order
minimums no delivery fees no running to
the store if you got the sauce the app
you've got a fully stocked bar on your
phone this is the future babies this is
the future babies for a limited time you
can get $15 off when you download the
saucy app and enter promo code Congrats
that's the saucy app spelled sau cey and
enter promo code congrats for $15 off
off get the saucy app today and use
promo code Congrats Square cash babies
you know what it is you're a longtime
listener you know what the square cash
app is everyone is switching to this
cash app because it's the best way to
pay people back period friends family
ghosts
anyone really setting and receiving
money is totally free and fast and most
payments can be deposited directly to
your bank account in second
you know how it works you download the
square the the square cash app linked to
your debit or credit card select an
amount to send and type in a friend's
phone number or email address to
complete a payment they'll get a
notification they just received money
that's it no gimmicks Square cash is
better than the other guys it's not a
social network who wants to have their
payments listed in a feed hmm you Koda
not me I don't want people to know when
I'm paying someone for sushi that's my
that's my business
if I paying for somebody for some
[ __ ] sushi me the new cash card is
cool because it's a black debit card
that you can design yourself via the app
you're artistic you got to mind your own
do it the cash card allows you to use
the cash that you keep in the app
anywhere you want you'll get the
notifications all the payments made with
the card directly via the cash app it's
you can laser etch it you can laser at
your card personalize it it'll be
delivered directly to you for free your
business card is crap get this laser
etched thing and get it now the cash app
team is constantly building new awesome
features it's very close to what were
you doing using the other guys get the
cash app today
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now my man true baby man no
kouddous no good like [ __ ] uh you
know the song TLC with the girl in the
band that died left I so sad too soon
anyway [ __ ] yeah do it I'm in a good
mood do it how about that I'm in a good
[ __ ] mood how about that how about
that how about that so knowing what I'm
doing Jesus Christ oh man all these guys
are getting exposed to dude I don't know
I wonder if one time I was in a urinal
at a [ __ ] nightclub in New York and
this gay guy I assumed he was gay I
think it was a gay club I was in I don't
know how I got up I wound up I was in
New York you know what I mean it was
[ __ ] I was 2 1
I had a gay friend and we went to like
this gay club or something
and he he was like this gay guy goes
like this nice cut oh nice kahi like
looked over to a nice [ __ ] you know
that's my story
but [ __ ] I was waiting for the
guy version of it
this whole Anthony rap thing I was
waiting for the [ __ ] guy version of
it and here it is it happened the guy
from Star Trek we should have known it
was gonna be a guy from Star Trek you
know Star Trek discovery or some [ __ ]
do they still do the how about that they
still do Star Trek um but yeah calling
out Kevin Spacey I want to know about
the guy how about the the the girl I
want to know about like you know what
you know who's [ __ ] you know who's
[ __ ] these are the two people that
are [ __ ] right now these are the two
people that are [ __ ] the people who
are next like you like you know I don't
want to name names cuz I don't know who
they are but there are people out there
that have done this [ __ ] like that James
Toby our guy or whatever the [ __ ]
310 women came forward like what a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that guy is and
then also he was [ __ ] he was
[ __ ] when that Weinstein stuff was
happening and then the guys that are
[ __ ] now that are like next on the
list and then also the women that were
like yeah or even the guys I bet there's
more guys that are like yeah I'll suck
your dick for parts like dude what about
those guys that like are in movies that
are famous now because they're like well
no I'm not gay but yeah I'll suck your
dick yeah sure [ __ ] me [ __ ] my butt [ __ ]
my butt off but pork my butt so I can be
in the Phantom Menace what about that
those guys are [ __ ] too because you
know you know so you know do you know
there's some guy out there that's gonna
get called out for doing the [ __ ] and
then he's just gonna [ __ ] be like
Tupac and he's gonna be like a father
yeah but what about when I [ __ ] that
war guy and that was in the Phantom
Menace yeah okay fine yeah I did some
grimy ass [ __ ] but what about how I [ __ ]
Hayden Christensen an average of star
you know take me to jail [ __ ]
how about [ __ ] you know I came
to think of another guy how about how
about [ __ ] Dennis Leary and put him in
the ref [ __ ] just found this out huh
that's new right house of cards canceled
you knew that was coming [ __ ] Wow Wow
it's a crazy [ __ ] time were living in
man Wow
why didn't they just kill him off you
know and have it be about Robin right
pant that would have been really
gangster that's what I would have done
[ __ ] him I'd be like you're not [ __ ]
my business up you know you're not
[ __ ] my business up bro yeah
assassinate him dude
do what happens when somebody dies treat
them like they're [ __ ] dead
I mean if someone's gonna be a piece of
[ __ ] and try and [ __ ] a 14 year old boy
put him out of your business bro don't
take your business down [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dude you know what no you know what you
do dude no you know what you really do
get another actor to play the guy [ __ ]
that get Anthony Rapp to play him you
know Oh bro
that [ __ ] that if I ran Netflix and
probably why I don't run anything bro I
would have been like hey Star Trek how
much do I have to pay to get Anthony
Rapp to now play [ __ ] Frank Underwood
is that the guy's name oh dude and you
know what straight up make him bald
dress him up try and get the best
special effects team no CGI no nothing
make me up like [ __ ] Kevin Spacey and
play [ __ ] house
arts and have can have Anthony Rapp be
like hello like do Kevin Spacey like I'm
the president now like play like him
gangster [ __ ] and then and then you know
he'd win the [ __ ] Emmy you know he'd
win the Emmy you know it
[ __ ] that dude gangster [ __ ]
[ __ ] you gonna let some kids you
out my business and I'm gonna take that
[ __ ] you drive to [ __ ] and put
him in my show yeah this how we gonna do
this
[ __ ] Kevin Spacey [ __ ] James Toby act
[ __ ] off you [ __ ] steam [ __ ] those
[ __ ] you came right on then
went we gonna take Anthony Rapp and he
gonna be the next Frank on the wood
that's
would be oh I'd never seen house of
cards you goddamn right I'm tuning in
and then wow wow it's amazing how much
how many people [ __ ] of effect it
affects you know it's like [ __ ] I mean
they [ __ ] they [ __ ] never uh the I
mean these people like all those people
are out of work now too you know besides
the fact that Anthony Rapp had to lift
that live with this for the rest of his
[ __ ] life since he was 14 which is
[ __ ] I mean do it if somebody tried to
like [ __ ] get on me and like [ __ ] me
and I was like wait and dude women have
to deal with this all the time and
that's so [ __ ] up but I guess you know
gay Hollywood has to deal with that a
lot I don't know should we take some
Twitter questions or some [ __ ] I'm like
that [ __ ] me up oh let's do the elder
we got a new elder babies Hey
on a brighter note sorry but it's it's
troubling times by the way when I was in
Australia everybody's so nice
I learned something when I was in
Australia everyone a lot of American
Americans generally are dicks dude let's
stop being dicks okay like [ __ ]
straight up dude the customer service in
Australia I thought by the end of every
customer experience I had I thought I
was dating them that's how nice they are
they talk to you they smile now first of
all I don't wanna be talked to all that
much that's fine and they they but they
they kind of like rode the line you know
they could tell when I don't want to be
talked to and they just felt it out but
dude people in America are dicks dude
people who work at the airport in
Australia are nice inhale at the
port the airports are like a [ __ ]
destination by the way but they're nice
in Australia they're nice
let me help you with your bags all were
you coming from ahahahaha laughs and
[ __ ] it's like they're your grandma or
your aunt or some [ __ ] in America we are
dicks
we are dicks dude we got to be better at
that [ __ ] man
don't be a [ __ ] dick dude
all right Eldar time this guy's overdue
actually Eric Brown is the next elder at
Eric Thomas be on Twitter so wish him a
congratulations for the congratulations
elder pin and certificate he made an
amazing animation of the segment of a
segment from episode 22 it's just you
can just YouTube it congratulations
podcast animated it's on my youtube
channel it's amazing it's it's beyond
Elder worthy this guy must have did must
have taken them [ __ ] seven years to
do check it out it's up on the YouTube
channel and let's give Eric a big
congratulations on Twitter we'll DM you
Eric with the details to get your pin
and certificate man and you got to rock
that pin the pins cool man I wear it on
my backpack people ask me what it means
all the time and that means that they're
not babies so whatever I have yet to
walk around and hold although I'm me but
I want to hear about stories there's
only like four elders so far by the way
we have a lot of elders that are our
common Ayari I told you I already said
this on the episode but we got a lot of
elders coming up that are just [ __ ]
long overdue that do some great great
stuff for the for the cult so yeah but
why don't we take some Twitter questions
huh your thoughts Matt [ __ ] tone that's
not his last name for real [ __ ] own s
SCH ITT Oh any [ __ ] one cool
hey Matt [ __ ] one well definitely if
that is your last name you've already
heard that and I'm sorry because that's
so [ __ ] hack but congratulations plod
your thoughts on people that bring
binoculars to a baseball game World
Series gaming the system here it well
now here's what it is if you have a kid
cool if you don't put them away if you
don't walk up closer that's the rule if
you got kids and you want to [ __ ]
show them and you want to share a moment
with your kids fine um
but bro put them na Killers away put
them NOC killers away
Carlos Barkley at young candle well 100%
change it young candle worst rap name
ever hey Krista Leah what's the most
Australian thing you've seen in
Australia well I mean the filthy ciggy
thing text was the most amazing thing
I've saw in Australia May I saw it
having a filthy ciggy but how about they
drive on the other side of the road and
it just [ __ ] every time I was in the
car it was it was scary a [ __ ] because I
was like oh oh and I would look both
ways across the street and I'd looked
the wrong way and I [ __ ] walk and I
almost get hit by cars I was like that
idiot foreigner that [ __ ] guy that
I'd be so mad at in America what's that
why do they have that yeah you
we're tweeting your CUDA shirts and your
other [ __ ] and oh and and and your your
true babies and all that [ __ ]
should we do [ __ ] up Instagram post of
the week I haven't looked and why let me
go to my oh hold er um God all of these
I've done already Jesus Christ this is a
good one well this is the first one that
came up on my oh hey guys it's time for
the most [ __ ] up Instagram post of the
week all right this one is a picture of
a guy in the desert standing alone with
one of those trendy what do they called
the [ __ ] remember when those things
were trendy these things those [ __ ]
neck I don't want to be racist but they
were like the neck what no I was like a
[ __ ] I can't do I got a it was like a
the the they put him over there scarves
when I call him I don't know maybe you
know what I'm talking about but they
were like white and black and they put
him around their neck people wearing him
one year all year yeah it was like it's
like it was like a me look Middle
Eastern I don't - I feel like I'm racist
no matter what the [ __ ] I say about
these things anyway you know what I'm
talking about he's got it all around his
face and it's probably a white guy
I mean look maybe hundra know if he's
white or what no it wasn't a helmet
anyway he's jacked of course because his
shirts off and that's the thing on
Instagram and it says the debt the
desert is the theater for human struggle
of searching dot dot dot for God what
the desert is the theater for okay first
of all the desert is not the theater
okay it's the desert it's it is so what
so that means what it already doesn't
mean anything and there's four words in
for the human struggle of searching for
God what it that it what does that even
mean does that mean anything
or is that just a bunch of [ __ ]
malarkey horseshit the desert is the
theater already means nothing I guess
you could say the desert is the theater
for scorpions but they don't do theater
so no but that's the only way you can in
that sentence is the desert is the
theater for camels but he says the
desert is the theater for the human
struggle I also don't like how he says
the human struggle just say human
struggle of searching dot dot dot what
do they call those that did ellipses for
God what so God's in the desert or some
[ __ ] that mean say yeah shemagh that's
what it's called shemagh and Brian are
saying all right
probably not saying it right anyway
that's the most [ __ ] up Instagram post
of the week and I'm about to wrap up
here this was a fun show because I was
just chilling relaxed and having a good
time
oh how about the [ __ ] thing i
retweeted it Southwest Airlines is gonna
[ __ ] have live music on an airplane
dude you know what I you know what I
don't want on that airplane period is
when they play the music it's so
annoying when you're somewhere and and
someone decides this is the music we're
going to listen to and you're
at a concert or like if you're at a
coffee shop they play the saddest emo
[ __ ] and I was on the [ __ ] plane
coming back and while we were all bored
and they were playing like some [ __ ]
what's that style of music were it
wasn't this song but it might as well
have been yeah beautiful was that James
Blunt like relax with that [ __ ] I'm
putting my [ __ ] duffel bag above my
seat and I got to start crying about
Allah like a breakup or some [ __ ] that I
don't even think about anymore I'm
[ __ ] putting a duffel bag above my
seat I'm making sure my [ __ ] tray
tables up and I got to hear some [ __ ]
song about it the ocean and in waves and
love [ __ ] and so besides the fact that
you're gonna have music on a plane
you're gonna have a band on the plane
and you're gonna charge me extra for a
checked bag what about the [ __ ]
singer and the [ __ ] backup vocal guys
what about how that costs money or what
they come on and sing while you're bored
and then leave all your not hey guy get
a gig what about what about are they on
the plane when you're on the dude yo you
got you better [ __ ] believe it I'll
be like hey get first of all they can
hear it
cuz that someone's [ __ ] rockin out
playing some [ __ ] Dave Matthews in
air it says Southwest has been hosting
in air shows occasionally since 2011 oh
my god
billboard reports that the series has
only grown in popularity over the past
six years as Southwest passengers hoped
that their flight will be one of the
lucky ones to feature of gold oh sure
dude hey I'll tell you right now I'll
never fly Southwest because of that if a
guy [ __ ] shows up with a gun first of
all I'm get mad when a guy brings his
guitar as a carry-on this guy's gonna be
plugging into an amplifier linear hair
Lemmy our hair or God he god forbid not
even covers he's gonna play hit his own
[ __ ] I gotta listen to some [ __ ]
[ __ ] new guy that's got three
thousand followers on Twitter some local
band that I'm gonna discover through
Southwest dude pack it up
hey if you're [ __ ] enjoying live music
on an aluminum - but 30,000 feet in the
air get captured I hope those are the
planes that go down by the way
for [ __ ] sake what's C he's he gonna
take on takeoff hey dude what about
turbulence what about in the middle of
the [ __ ] linear ha ha so the captain
has decided to put on the seat belt
because of some turbulence so everyone
take your seats okay and then the [ __ ]
we're gonna have to take the mic stand
and then the [ __ ] steward stewardess
I'm sir you have to actually put your
seat up to the band guy you have to put
your seat up
sir you need to put your guitar above
the thing it doesn't fit oh I'm oh okay
well you guys hired me sing but okay
okay well okay oh I'm the biggest [ __ ]
alive okay oh I'm I'm a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
oh you treat me like a piece of [ __ ]
okay I mean God you know you guys just
hired me to sing some James Blunt but
yeah yeah yeah I'll put my tray table up
okay excuse me that guitar expensive
actually handle it with care okay thank
you okay and now you're free to walk
around the cabin no should we just start
with I mean I'm gonna wrap this up dude
don't fly Southwest cuz of that but I'd
still rather fly Southwest then [ __ ]
United how about that huh all right
square cash have you switched yet
download the free square cash app design
your cash card get it for iOS or Android
now a new shirt up in the store there's
a new shirt up in the store then Okuda
shirt and it's awesome it's it's I might
be my favorite every new one is kind of
my favorite because it's new and I like
the new [ __ ] but this one is awesome I
really like this true baby one two the
two newest two newest the two newest
subscribe rate and review the show
please it helps me out more people are
watching the video on YouTube but I want
to get those podcast numbers up too so
help me out help us out it's us really
if we're if you're in the cult
hashtag congratulations pod hope you're
enjoying the video episodes on YouTube
videos go up every Thursday by the
latest they go up on Thursdays at the
latest so do that upcoming upcoming
shows buy tickets at crystally accom
Columbus Ohio a lot I think I might be
sold out I might be I think I had it
another show if I didn't it'll come up
soon Irvine San Jose Riverside on New
Year's Eve didn't know that until right
now but yes I remember saying yes to
that so join me in Riverside Winnipeg
Calgary I added a new show in Winnipeg
Calgary tickets almost the
man on fire watch it REE watch it like
it or whatever are on Netflix and on
Netflix and thank you for listening you
guys it's been great
it's been a great [ __ ] thing here man
back in America sayonara my babies until
next time
[Music]
you